saludos en esta ocasión quiero hablarles
sobre la frecuencia de pulsación y para
hacerlo permítanme hablarles de esta
gráfica de desplazamiento de aire contra
el tiempo esto nos va a dar un
desplazamiento de las moléculas de aire
durante cualquier momento del tiempo en
una ubicación particular digamos que
tenemos una bocina que está tocando una
nota agradable armónica simple que va a
sonar algo así
estos son 440 hertz que es la nota la y
las personas la ocupan mucho cuando
están afinando instrumentos y así se
escucha este sonido y hay una región
particular en el espacio en donde
medimos cuál es el desplazamiento de las
moléculas de aire como una función del
tiempo digamos que estamos a tres metros
a la derecha de la bocina
tenemos moléculas de aire por acá
tranquilas y relajadas y entonces llega
la onda de sonido y hace que estas
moléculas de aire se desplacen se muevan
de un lado a otro
una cantidad minúscula y si gráfica mos
este desplazamiento como función del
tiempo vamos a tener esta gráfica en
otras palabras esta gráfica está
personalizada para esta región del
espacio a tres metros de la bocina
porque les digo esto porque sabemos que
si super ponemos dos ondas digamos que
aquí tengo otra onda y a menos que esta
onda tenga exactamente el mismo periodo
que la
dónde las ponemos pico con pico para que
veamos que tienen el mismo periodo por
lo que les lleva el mismo tiempo a cada
una de ellas recorrer un ciclo completo
si la super pongo es decir tomó otra
bocina y toco la misma nota que la
primera y las pongo juntas
voy a escuchar interferencia
constructiva ya que estas ondas se van a
estar superponiendo pico con pico y
valle con valle perfectamente por lo que
este sonido se va a ser más alto si yo
estuviera aquí parada escuchando y
permanecería alto este sonido todo el
tiempo y esto se debe a que tenemos
interferencia constructiva todo el
tiempo si adelantará un poquito la
segunda bocina o se intercambiará el
cableado o encontrara alguna forma de
disfrazar estas ondas de manera que
tuviera una interferencia destructiva
escucharía una nota más suave si no es
que silencio completo ya que sería una
interferencia perfectamente destructiva
y permanecería en silencio todo el día
ya que todo el tiempo permanecería como
interferencia destructiva por lo que si
super ponemos dos ondas que tienen la
misma frecuencia es decir tienen el
mismo periodo entonces si tenemos
interferencia constructiva va a
permanecer como constructiva todo el
tiempo o si tenemos interferencia
destructiva va a permanecer así
destructiva todo el tiempo
pero aquí ocurre algo loco vamos a
quitar esto qué pasaría si super
pusiéramos dos ondas que tuvieran
periodos diferentes qué pasaría pues
vamos a averiguarlo vamos a usar esta
onda esta tiene un período diferente
véanlo aquí si las comparó los picos no
siempre se van a alinear puedo ver que
la distancia entre estos dos picos no es
la misma que la distancia entre estos
dos valles es casi la misma distancia
pero no es igual la onda roja tiene un
periodo ligeramente más grande que la
onda azul el tiempo entre picos en la
onda roja es un poco mayor que el tiempo
entre picos en la onda azul y quizá
ustedes piensen que es una diferencia
muy pequeña y no debería tener tanto
problema cierto pues no esto nos va a
ocasionar un nuevo fenómeno que le
llamamos frecuencia de pulsación y vamos
a ver como ocurre
y super pongo estas dos ondas ahora
tenemos dos bocinas pero cada una está
tocando una onda diferente
la segunda bocina va a tener una onda
con una frecuencia ligeramente diferente
que es lo que vamos a tener pues veamos
qué pasa comienzan en fase en este punto
se superponen perfectamente y coincide
pico con pico por lo que aquí tenemos
interferencia constructiva aquí tenemos
que esta onda comienza con una
interferencia constructiva con la
segunda onda quiere decir que si ustedes
están en este punto en este instante del
tiempo recuerden que este eje es el del
tiempo no espacio por lo que en este
instante de tiempo escucharemos
interferencia constructiva lo que
significa que estas ondas van a sonar
más alto pero después esperamos y esta
onda roja tiene un periodo un poco más
grande por lo que le va a llevar más
tiempo a esta onda roja a completar un
ciclo lo que significa que estas ondas
van a comenzar a desplazarse
ya no se van a alinear por lo que cuando
la onda azul ha desplazado las moléculas
de aire la cantidad máxima que puede
hacerlo hacia la derecha
la onda roja aún no habrá logrado esto
le llevará más tiempo hacerlo así que se
van desplazando y aquí vamos teniendo
interferencia cada vez menos
constructiva vean que aquí el pico
coincide con el valle por lo que aquí de
plano hay interferencia destructiva y el
sonido será muy suave y si la
interferencia fuera perfectamente
destructiva aquí escucharíamos silencio
y si esperamos un poco más veremos que
esta onda azul básicamente ya coincide
con la onda roja
hemos esperado tanto tiempo que ahora a
la onda azul le ha dado tiempo de
recorrer un ciclo completo con respecto
a la onda roja por lo que de nuevo los
picos coinciden aquí y de nuevo tenemos
interferencia constructiva porque los
picos coinciden con los picos y los
valles con los valles por lo que
en este momento tenemos interferencia
constructiva y el sonido va a ser alto
otra vez que es lo que escucharíamos si
estuviéramos en este punto a tres metros
de las bocinas en ese momento del tiempo
escucharíamos la nota alta luego
escucharemos que se vuelve más suave y
después escucharíamos que vuelve a
hacerse más alta escucharíamos que esta
onda oscila el nombre que le damos a
este fenómeno es frecuencia de pulsación
oa veces les llamamos pulsos y no son
cualquier tipo de pulsos y no nos
referimos a pulsos cardiacos
simplemente nos referimos a las
oscilaciones que van de alto a suave y
así sucesivamente
es más permítanme mostrarles cómo suena
esto si tocamos la nota la de 440 hertz
esta tiene una frecuencia particular 440
hertz ahora escuchen una frecuencia
ligeramente diferente
esta nota tiene 443
a ustedes les suene exactamente igual y
no noten la diferencia entre las dos
pero si toco ambas al mismo tiempo
definitivamente van a poder escuchar la
diferencia esta es la nota de 443 hertz
y esta es la de 440 hertz y ahora
escuchan una oscilación
vamos a detener esto y es a esto a lo
que se refieren los físicos cuando
hablan de frecuencia de pulsación o de
pulsos es esta oscilación o el cambio en
el volumen del sonido de estas ondas que
ocurre cuando super ponemos dos ondas
que tienen frecuencias ligeramente
diferentes y esto es importante esto
sólo ocurre cuando tenemos ondas con
diferentes frecuencias y qué pasaría si
quisiéramos conocer cuál es la
frecuencia de esta pulsación cuántas
oscilaciones tendremos en un segundo qué
tan seguido pasa de interferencia
constructiva a destructiva y de nuevo a
constructiva si esto le lleva mucho
tiempo la frecuencia va a ser pequeña ya
que no tendremos muchas oscilaciones por
segundo pero si esto le lleva poco
tiempo no hay mucho tiempo entre
interferencia constructiva
luego destructiva y luego constructiva
entonces la frecuencia de pulsación va a
ser más grande tendremos muchas
oscilaciones por segundo como calculamos
esta frecuencia de pulsación que le
llamaremos f
esto nos dice cuántas veces pasamos de
constructiva a destructiva y luego a
constructiva otra vez cada segundo si
hace esto 20 veces por segundo esto
estará oscilando 20 veces por segundo y
la frecuencia será de 20 hertz como
encontramos esto si conocemos la
frecuencia de cada una de las ondas
individuales pues resulta que es
bastante sencillo ahorita les voy a
mostrar la fórmula y en un vídeo
posterior veremos como reducirla para
aquellos de ustedes que estén
interesados pero en este vídeo les
mostraré la fórmula que es bastante
fácil y les enseñaré cómo usarla si yo
conozco la frecuencia de la primera onda
la onda aún no tiene una frecuencia 1 y
digamos que mi onda azul es la onda 1 y
la onda 2 tiene una frecuencia 2 que es
mi onda roja
yo puedo encontrar la frecuencia de
pulsación al encontrar la diferencia
entre estas dos frecuencias tomo f1 y le
restó f 2 y es tan sencillo como esto
así es como encontramos la frecuencia de
pulsación pero
quizás ustedes me digan a ver un momento
qué sucede si f 1 es más pequeña que f 2
acaso podemos tener frecuencias
negativas pues no no tendría sentido no
podemos tener frecuencias negativas así
que aquí típicamente ponemos el símbolo
de valor absoluto debemos tomar la
frecuencia más grande y restarle la más
pequeña pero en el caso en el que no
sepan cuál es más grande o cuál más
pequeña usen el símbolo del valor
absoluto lo que les dará el tamaño de
esta frecuencia de pulsación que es el
número de oscilaciones por segundo es
decir el número de veces que pasa de
constructiva a destructiva y
constructiva en un segundo es decir
cuántas veces pasa de constructiva a
constructiva de nuevo en un segundo a
esto se refiere la frecuencia de
pulsación y con esta fórmula podemos
encontrarla ahora permítanme aclarar
algo al superponer dos ondas nuestros
oídos solamente van a escuchar una onda
total por lo que estas ondas se
superponen y pueden hacer todo este
análisis
la interferencia de onda escribe en la
ecuación de una de las ondas escribe en
la ecuación de la otra onda y suman
ambas sabemos que la onda total va a ser
igual a la contribución de la onda 1 más
la contribución de la onda 2 en un
momento particular del tiempo así que si
elegimos un momento en el tiempo y
sumamos la contribución de cada una de
las ondas en ese instante obtendremos la
onda total en ese momento y cómo luciría
la onda total para todo este rango de
tiempo pues se vería así como esta onda
verde punteada aquí la suma da el doble
de las originales y en el medio se
cancelan casi a cero y luego por acá
vuelve a aumentar porque se suman
nuevamente si vemos solamente la onda
total lúcida así la onda total comienza
con una amplitud más grande luego va
bajando casi hasta llegar a cero en
donde se vuelve destructiva y después la
amplitud va aumentando poco a poco hasta
que llegue al máximo por lo que veremos
este tipo de onda cuando estemos
hablando de frecuencias
ya que nos muestra como luce la onda
total como función del tiempo al sumar
nuestras dos ondas individuales y aquí
pasa de constructivo y luego otra vez a
constructivo es por eso que suena alto
suave y alto como sería un problema
ejemplo de esto digamos que nos dicen
que hay una flauta y esta flauta está
tocando con una frecuencia de 440 hertz
como la nota que escuchamos al principio
y también nos dicen que hay un clarinete
y se supone que ambos instrumentos están
bien afinados para poder tener una buena
presentación ante la audiencia pero
cuando estos instrumentos tratan de
tocar la nota la la flauta toca a 440
hertz pero el clarinete al tocar su nota
resulta que escuchamos una frecuencia de
pulsación de 5 hertz es decir escuchamos
5 oscilaciones en un segundo y de hecho
si alguna vez han tratado de afinar un
instrumento sabrán que una forma de
afinar lo es tratar de escuchar dos
notas que se suponen son la misma
pueden darse cuenta inmediatamente si no
son iguales porque escucharán estas
oscilaciones por lo que siguen afinando
hasta que ya no escuchen ninguna
oscilación conforme estas notas se van
acercando entre sí tendremos menos
oscilaciones por segundo y cuando
dejemos de escuchar oscilaciones
totalmente entonces estarán exactamente
a la misma frecuencia y esto no ocurre
aquí aquí están desafinadas la pregunta
aquí es cuáles son las dos frecuencias
posibles que tiene el clarinete que
puede tener el clarinete sabemos que la
frecuencia de pulsación es el valor
absoluto de la diferencia entre ambas
frecuencias por lo que si tenemos una
frecuencia de pulsación de 5 hertz y la
flauta tiene una frecuencia de 440 hertz
quiere decir que el clarinete tiene 5
hertz de desfase con respecto a la
flauta por lo que el clarinete quizás
está un poco alto quizá tenga unos 445
hertz o podría tener 435 hertz estar un
poco abajo
tenemos que afinar lo hasta llegar a la
frecuencia de 440 hertz y nuestra
frecuencia de pulsación sea cero porque
cuando esta frecuencia de pulsación es
cero nosotros sabemos que ambas
frecuencias son iguales pero qué hacemos
como saber cuál es la frecuencia que
tiene este clarinete pues a veces no
sabemos a veces solo tenemos que hacer
las pruebas para poder afinar lo digamos
que suponemos que nuestro clarinete está
más alto tiene 445 hertz por lo que
queremos bajar su tono comenzamos a
afinar lo hacia abajo y qué es lo que
tenemos que escuchar pues queremos
escuchar menos oscilaciones por segundo
por lo que si queremos que esté afinada
en lugar de escuchar govou queremos
escuchar
y conforme nos vamos acercando a la
frecuencia correcta escucharemos wow
hasta que ya no escuchemos oscilaciones
si esta persona tratara de hacer esto y
escuchará más oscilaciones por segundo
entonces probablemente se dé cuenta de
que realmente el clarinete estaba en
esta frecuencia más baja ya que si yo
estaba en 435 hertz y voy bajando a 430
hertz pues va a estar más desafinada y
ahora la frecuencia de pulsación será de
10 hertz escucharíamos 10 oscilaciones
por segundo y esta persona se daría
cuenta inmediatamente de que no es una
buena idea la frecuencia del clarinete
no estaba muy alta estaba muy baja por
lo que debemos afinar la en el otro
sentido para poder elevar esta
frecuencia hasta los 440 hearts y
entonces escucharíamos 0 frecuencia de
pulsación 0 oscilaciones por segundo
ahora sí estaría afinado y estaríamos
tocando en armonía en resumen los pulsos
o la frecuencia de pulsación ocurre
cuando super ponemos dos ondas que
tienen frecuencias diferentes esto
que las ondas pasen de ser constructivas
a destructivas y luego de nuevo a
constructivas una y otra y otra vez y
esto lo percibimos como una oscilación
en el volumen del sonido y la forma en
la que podemos encontrar la frecuencia
de pulsación es tomando la diferencia de
las frecuencias individuales que se
están superponiendo